about other uh popular mag magicians or
illusionists like let's just say David
Blaine do you have relationships with
those guys like do you ever like do you
collab do you beef or anything like that
like what's like I don't know how's your
relationships
going all right I'm going to tell you a
story that I have not told anyone wow
all right so listen David Blaine I give
props to he came out did street magic
you know blew up before I did and give
him all the props in the world um when
he was when he was coming up you know I
I was very aggressive um because I had a
dream I had a vision in my mind I wanted
to accomplish
it so you know I would say look whatever
David is doing I can do it and I'll do
it side by side with him and I guarantee
you that whatever he does I'll last
longer I'll do it better I'll do
whatever because I was committed to give
my life to beating him or anyone else
because I had something so bad that I
wanted and he had it so he had a big
Target on his head and so um you know I
uh since then recently last year went to
go see his show and um you know it's
nothing personal it was just like people
do it to me all the time and it's like
bring it it's it's totally like part of
the thing because in the magic world
it's you know if you go up to somebody
on the street and you say name five
magicians they have a difficult time
doing that it's very it's a very small
place at the top yeah and especially you
know what what I'm doing with live and
television and stuff so anyway I saw him
and I I I uh went to his show and I was
like dude you know I just want to WIP
this SL clean I haven't I've never met
you before so I just want to say like
you know no hard feelings like I I
apologize for anything that might have
offended you or anything like that and
um I took off I had a beautiful
beautiful ring gorgeous ring like 20 G's
I took it off and I said this is for you
and I said let's let's you know build a
friendship and stuff like that because
I'm talking this was in like in in like
the early what 2000s that this went down
it like so many years ago and I gave it
to him and uh and he's like oh I don't I
can't accept this because I'm a
minimalist and and then he called this
friend over I was like hey let's put it
in a
museum you know like you could do
whatever you want that I'm giving it to
you and then the guy comes in he's like
oh okay thank you I like well I gave it
to David yeah if he wants to give it to
you that's his business because it's a
gift for
me and then I was like hey let's do a
picture and he's like oh I can't do a
picture with just you and me alone
and it's just [__] bizarre dude like
just bizarre behavior and it's like dude
grow up like it's it's it's like you
know we're both adults we both have
children I had a kid with cancer like
you know it wasn't like we had a fist
fight it's not like we ever even met
before it's not like we ever even had a
conversation on the phone nothing it was
just some banter in the in the Press
because I because I wanted to succeed
and you know he's ripped me off with
stuff that I've done you know like I've
been under the water for 24 hours and he
borrowed that and then he did it later
which is totally cool like God bless him
like it's not a big deal do your thing
man it's it's all good but life is too
short to sit here and and uh but you
know the truth is is that I'm out there
I'm doing my thing pretty successful at
doing it and uh I never look behind me
wow
that's uh yes so you guys aren't having
dinner together all the mag no I
I I text him after it like you think he
would say hey Chris thanks for the you
know the ring or whatever I texted him
and I was like hey man happy Father's
Day thanks for having us at the show
whatever and uh never responded so I was
like cool dude like it's all good like I
wish wish him and everyone else the best
yeah life is too short man and when you
have a kid with cancer and you realize
how fragile life is all this other [__]
like you never see a hearse pulling a
U-Haul it means nothing yeah means
nothing especially like you know when
you want to put love light and
positivity in the world right yeah I I
read about your kid having leukemia yeah
and doing going Johnny Christopher yeah
yeah thousand treatments well he went
through
1,95 days then he went to remission
which is three years he went to
remission for less than a year he got a
a it it basically uh came back I found
it in his testicles when he came out of
the shower I was like look that I was
like this doesn't look normal let's go
to it and then he went through another
two years of treatment so he was in it
for over six years and now my whole
mission in life and the reason why I
believe I was blessed was for the
betterment of children like I raise
millions of dollars for kids every cent
that I raise one 100% of every scent I
raise goes to um these kids um cure for
the kids here in Las Vegas is a
treatment center that treated Johnny and
other kids even if they don't have
insurance um make a wish of Southern
Nevada you know I uh uh does a lot of
really good things to give kids the
incentive to get through treatment a
look forward for mentally to do and so
you know my whole mission in life is to
earmark that money make sure it doesn't
go to like expenses or overhead I pay
all of that out of my pocket we just
raised I think on December um what was
it the the 18th um day before my
birthday I had a big event I had a bunch
of bands that you would love that just
play Cheap Trick and nice and um fast a
pussycat Ellie gun Skid Row uh uh bunch
of bands anyway they um we raised uh
about a million over a million six and
it all goes to kids and I raise money
every show so that's my mission in life
you know that's that's that's that's
what I'm here to try to do and I'm so
blessed that my kid is doing good he's
in school and uh you know it's just but
you never know man it's it's fragile
it's scary I mean leukemia is just kind
of like hit her Miss there's no causes
for it one child every two minutes is
diagnosed with um pediatric cancer J and
um you know that's that's a huge number
one child every two minutes so um you
know not to bring the show down but if
people want to help they can go to
chrisangel.com they can watch a
documentary I made that's 13 minutes
long it's called 1095 5 and it's
basically about 13 minutes long took six
years to make about what we went through
and people can donate a dollar or watch
here it is right here yeah so um that's
the documentary right there people can
watch that and that share it and if they
feel compelled donate a dollar if they
don't just share it and uh hopefully we
can raise awareness and money and make
pediatric cancer disappear because it's
uh when you see kids and I go to
hospitals and I see these kids uh it's
um it really puts everything in
perspective you know really puts
everything in perspective cuz they're so
[__] innocent it should be worrying
about playing with their toy not like I
have I have to sit there and get chemo
for how many hours or do a blood
transfusion or do a spinal tap or you
know all the [__] my my son was hooked
up to blindat Tuma maab uh basically you
know a machine 28 days a month every
other month it was I tried to do it he
lost all his hair that's him in the in
the bed obviously uh there and uh it's a
it's a difficult situation so for me
that puts everything into perspective
and everything else you know is um a
blessing every moment is a gift that's
why you have to live your life doing
what you want to do put love light and
positivity out there don't do something
you hate to do for a living try to do
something life is too short you know
anyway do you like shopping on Amazon I
do and good news is Evo butt wipes for
your butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get sto's hot sauce for your
butthole plus sto's butthole destroyer
and steo butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right
now yeah dude